uh there's an element yes there's a
strong element of not getting invited to
things you used to get invited to for
sure yeah uh not not with certain
friends or older friends or guys have
known for a long time or you know that
sort of stuff but yeah sure there's
there's an element of that
that's what they do they're
you know first off they're cowards
secondly there's something
they're into mccarthyism big time which
is weird because they never shut up
about mccarthyism but they love to
practice mccarthyism every chance they
get and then they complain more about
mccarthyism
um so yeah that's that's what hollywood
does
are you surprised that all of this is so
idiotic that everyone involved with all
of this at every level seems like a
complete [ __ ] or incomplete dereliction
of their duty or an idiot or an
incompetent or a psychopath i mean you
feeling you feel free to use some other
adjectives like just the whole thing
there's just nobody
well look as i've said many times
if you can argue the definition but of
what is a woman or the difference
between a man and woman if if that's
open to debate
then
going to the border or a recession is
certainly on the table
you know what i mean like if you really
think about
the ultimate black and white definition
man woman okay that's out the window so
a recession that's easy to argue away if
you can argue away a woman you know what
i mean and i sort of think a lot of
that's the motivation for a lot of it
because
they will argue away anything now
because everything is on on the table
now the the question you're sort of
asking is is
well you know joe biden kamal harris
whomever
i get it
that's their job
but i mean it's insane but that's what
they're doing
the question is more like what are the
news outlets doing
what are they aren't they worried about
their credibility don't they sound
insane
i i mean
i get it you're a cheerleader for a
party
but at what you know you're essentially
saying i'm a cheerleader in a football
game and the other team just scored and
you go no they didn't
it's like yes they did no well what is
your definition of a touchdown then it's
like
cnn you sound insane
and people stop listening and why are
you making this deal with the devil why
are you cashing in every
bit of goodwill you've earned over the
last 50 years
on
stupid things just give it up
you know this this this or or going like
all in on january 6 you know it's the
worst you know of democracy hanging by a
thread the worst attack since pearl
harbor like your news outlet or
ivermectins for horses
you know why are you why are you
giving it up
why are you playing so fast and loose
with your dignity
your news outlet
you
do you think it's too late and we should
just encourage their slow or i guess at
this point they're relatively quick
death it's been a slow death that i
think is now escalating
um i don't know like my feeling is is uh
if somebody popped onto msnbc and said
look um
we traditionally
define a recession as two quarters of
negative growth and that's what we got
so that's what we're in i'd go all right
well at least that guy's
sounds semi-shane
right but there aren't too many of those
guys over there but you know i've asked
you this before but i don't think we've
done anything on camera since since you
brought me back from off the grid last
september so about 11 months ago
you're a hollywood guy you've
you've had a lot of success in hollywood
you still live in la when you think
about all of these the people that
you're talking about that are just sort
of in on all of the lies i mean an awful
lot of the hollywood people they're just
they're just kind of in the lie do you
get invited to any parties anymore
when's the last time you've been out of
the house
um well i'm out now technically
but not to your own building
since since you left i don't get invited
to too many parties
is it really like that like
uh there's an element yes there's a
strong element of not getting invited to
things you used to get invited to for
sure yeah uh not not with certain
friends or older friends or guys have
known for a long time or you know that
sort of stuff but yeah sure there's
there's an element of that
that's what they do they're you know
first off they're cowards
secondly there's something
they're into mccarthyism big time which
is weird because they never shut up
about mccarthyism but they love to
practice mccarthyism every chance they
get and then they complain more about
mccarthyism
um so yeah that's that's what hollywood
does
tell me about the book here because when
i saw the uh the cover here and i saw
the title everything reminds me of
something but this is corolla because
that's you right like when you when
you're doing your show everything that
you hear you're interviewing somebody
you're doing the news everything reminds
you of something that happened way back
when that that is the adam corolla
yeah
it's something i came out of my mouth
like five years ago and i went yeah
that's true everything does remind me of
something and i thought it'd be a good
title
for a book
and
the book is people asking questions
versus me sitting down
and posing my own questions
which is kind of what you do when you
write a book you go well here's what i
want to talk about and here's in it it's
it's an interesting conceit because it's
like
a authoring a book is sort of asking
yourself a question like what should we
do about the homeless problem here's
what we need to do about the homeless
problem you know but this is a little
different and that people were asking me
questions and i had to form thoughts and
opinions on questions that i wasn't
asking myself so i found myself going
hmm
yeah why is that and then i was kind of
pushed outside of my box and had to
figure out what is the answer to that
question because they were not my own
yeah what's like the most burning thing
that you were asked that you really
maybe hadn't thought through you you're
a thinker you you're doing a daily
podcast man you talk to people on the
internet
uh the one that pops into my head
and there were many but the one i i
remember and you also
people have to remember or consider
i write these books i write them
while i'm doing 10 other things and then
they come out and then people go what's
your favorite chapter whatever it is i
can't remember anything i did i i was
there i did it and now i'm gone and i
don't know
um but
uh somebody said
in a world that's very equitable now in
2022 where
males and females sort of share a lot of
the same duties and there's
more women in college these days and
more women attorneys than male attorneys
why is it when you
see a motorcycle going down the road
with a couple on it the guy is still the
guy with his hands on the handlebars and
the woman is pulled in behind him with
her hands on his waist
why
and i was like i yeah have some thoughts
i'll let you i'll let you answer yeah
your own question no i'm i'm see now
this is what happened to me i was like
yeah i never thought of that but it's
true
i've not seen any women riding the bike
with the guy in the back
but in a world where we the guy stays
home and takes care of the kids and the
woman goes to work and you know he's
making dinner and everything all the
responsibilities are shared now
why do we still have this
in this one place also it's like
see a lot of women driving with a guy in
the passenger seat now you know you
didn't see that so much when i was
growing up so i'll be curious your take
on that and then i'll tell you what i
said if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell